how to promote a book so I got a great
question for one of my newsletter
readers love you guys
Olga wrote in the say since the release
of my first book god for the modern
woman
I am constantly seeking out ways to
promote this book which I believe is
very valuable perhaps you can show me
ways to promote a book when most of
today's talk shows just want laughter
jokes and discussion of movies they're
not eager to discuss why history repeats
itself and why no matter how hard some
people try the world is filled with
violence and despair this is a fantastic
question Olga thank you so much for
asking it and there are so many people
who create books right I'm in the
process of writing my own now to write
seems like everybody has a book these
days that the difference is gonna be you
know obviously one what you put into the
book but then two in the promotion and
the marketing and letting people know
about it and spreading your message and
it almost sounds like you've kind of
given up on that and you face a lot of
rejection and people say no that you're
in a hole and this happens a lot of
entrepreneurs right you get a lot of
nose and and you start to give up you
start to lose faith you start to lose
your motivation you stop believing right
and the number one tip I have for you is
you have to change your mindset so yes a
lot of people in the news industry want
to cover violence and Wars and all the
things that's wrong with the world right
you turn on the nightly news and that's
what you're gonna see in your face all
the time you look at the newspaper the
front page that's what you're gonna see
a lot of the times but you have to
change your mindset and know that there
are people who want to say yes there are
people who love your message there are
people who want to talk about this you
just have to find them and there's a big
difference in shifting your thinking
from saying I'm the only one in the
world and nobody cares about this -
there are some people who want to say
yes I've gotten interviews and featured
in New York Times and Wall Street
Journal and Forbes magazine and all of
the big press that covers
entrepreneurship in some format and my
message has always been positive it's
always been uplifting people believing
in people and there are reporters there
are people in the media who want to hear
that message so before you even start
you have to approach it with that
mindset approach it knowing that there
are people who believe in what you're
doing
who want to say yes who want to cover
you because if you go in thinking this
isn't gonna work you're not really gonna
do it you're not really gonna believe in
it it's not going to be great whatever
you reach out with so first change your
mindset
number two is have a powerful message
what am I going to learn from this book
what is it that you stand for how am I
gonna be uplifted by it what are you
gonna teach me quick short simple
powerful tell me what I'm gonna learn
write all of my stuff is about belief
that's obvious right it oozes out of
every video I make it comes in every
newsletter every social media tweet
every YouTube video it pours out I want
to feel that from you right what am I
gonna learn from this book you wrote me
a lot more in in that email but I'm not
getting something powerful from it right
you got a shorten down that message make
it ideally one word find your one word
make it powerful hit me with it so I'm
curious to want to learn more so now
that you've changed your mindset now
we're crafting a powerful pitch that has
meaning deep meaning that will move
people that's how you need to start and
number three is reach out so now that
we've changed our mindset we have a
powerful message it's making a list of
targeted people to reach out to so you
want to connect with offline media and
online media old media and new media you
can reach out to all the people who are
at the big publications or at the New
York Times and Wall Street Journal or
whoever covers your industry right
people who have an uplifting message
people who want to build PP up people up
those people exist why do you think
Oprah became so successful it's a
powerful positive uplifting message so
you want to make that list right and
also look at the online guys look at
youtubers look at bloggers look at
people who have Twitter followings and
connect with them right if somebody
wrote to me and said Evan I've got this
new book it's about believing in
entrepreneurs I'm all ears I want to
read that book I want to learn about it
I might profile that person that person
might be on my next YouTube video right
because they have an uplifting message
they believe they could find someone
like me who has an audience who can help
them right they change their mindset
do they have that powerful message that
connects with me that is clear to
articulate and three they reached out
and I get pitch I can't tell you how
many times I get pitched by people who
are just trying to promote their product
that has no feeling behind it that isn't
even catered towards entrepreneurs
they're just trying to reach out to
anybody who has a big audience and they
always get rejected most the time I
don't even write back to them because
it's obvious that they did zero work in
targeting the right person but if people
have entrepreneur related products and
they have a powerful uplifting message
I'm interested now it's not a guarantee
that they're gonna be on my channel that
I'm gonna profile them I'm gonna talk
about them but I'm at you got in the
door I'm at least interested then it's
up to your book to actually do the work
right if you say you have a great book
about believing entrepreneurs and you
send me a book and I don't like it well
the quality wasn't there but that's your
foot in the door so number one change
your mindset number two have a powerful
message and number three reach out and
believe those you're watching the video
you like you want to see more you can
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much for watching I'll see you soon
don't forget to click here to subscribe
to my newsletter to get actionable
inspiring motivational believe advice
every single week to your inbox hi I'm
Jason Grif on sigur rós online calm and
I want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's the only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period